Herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio 273, wo wir wie Bösezungen behaupten würden, ausnahmsweise mal Digitalisierung konstruktiv gestalten wollen. Also weil ihr, wenn ihr euch nicht nicht in die allzu ferne Vergangenheit zurückdenkt, von nur zwei Sendungen haben wir schon mal drüber gesprochen, was eine Bundestagswahl möglicherweise verändern könnte und haben da aber vor allem darüber gesprochen, was alles schief gelaufen ist. Das soll heute anders werden und Anlass ist, dass der Chaos Computer Club, dem das Chaos Radio ja mehr oder weniger gehört, eine Liste herausgebracht hat, die dazu dienen soll, den geneigten PolitikerInnen zu zeigen, was man besser machen sollte, wenn man ein gutes digitales Leben ermöglichen möchte. Ich möchte zuallererst allerdings einen Gast begrüßen, der in der vor zwei Sendungen auch schon dabei war, nämlich Anna Biselli von Netzpolitik. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zurück.
Hallo.
Dass du heute hier bist, sagt mir, dass es zumindest Hoffnung gibt, dass es Sinn macht, darüber zu reden, was man besser machen könnte.
Also es ist ja nie hoffnungslos.
Wollen wir mal gucken, wie weit wir damit kommen. Von dem Verein, der diese Liste aufgestellt hat, begrüße ich recht herzlich Erdgeist, einer aus dem Sprecherteam des CCC. Hallo und herzlich willkommen.
Wunderschönen guten Abend.
Und dann, jetzt wird es kompliziert, Fiona Krakenburger, die sich schon sehr lange in verschiedenen Positionen mit Open Source Funding beschäftigt hat, gerade bei der Alfred Landecker Foundation, auch zur Förderung arbeitet. Aber Achtung, nebenbei auch Mitautorin einer Studie für das BMWi war. Und das ist eine Machbarkeitsstudie für ein Förderprogramm Infrastruktur und Open Source. Das wird heute möglicherweise auch eine Rolle spielen. Hallo und herzlich willkommen. War das jetzt eigentlich richtig vorgestellt?
Es war perfekt. Viele scheitern schon am Nachnamen. Du hast das alles super hinbekommen.
Möge meine Vorstellungskompetenz sich auf die Digitalkompetenz der Bundesregierung übertragen. Lieber Herr Erdgeist, bevor wir über das Inhaltliche reden, was hat euch eigentlich geritten, so eine Liste aufzustellen? Ist das tatsächlich ein ernst gemeinter Vorschlag? Hier sind ein paar Dinge, an denen ihr arbeiten könnt? Oder ist das einfach eine Vorbereitung, um in vier Jahren sagen zu können, told you so?
Ich fürchte, dazu sind wir im CCC jetzt ein bisschen zu alt schon. Wenn wir uns in vier Jahren hinstellen, dann ist eigentlich schon alles geritten. Und dann können wir wahrscheinlich einpacken. Dann haben wir immer noch kein Internet, dann haben wir immer noch irgendwelche großen IT-Projekte, die kaputt geritten wurden von Politikern, die am liebsten ihren Namen zu irgendwas, was modern klingt, in den Nachrichten hätten. Das wollen wir einfach nicht mehr. Wir haben jetzt die Gelegenheit einer frischen Regierung, die gerne zeigen möchte, was die Alte alles falsch gemacht hat, Handreichungen geben, wie sie sich möglichst schnell differenzieren kann und wie der frische Wind den so einen Regierungsprogramm, was sich in diesen Formulierungshelfen orientieren würde, wie dieser frische Wind die Gesellschaft sofort voranbringen könnte, als dass die Regierung sich selber als Erfolgsprojekt verkaufen könnte.
Vielleicht hättest du doch überlegen, Politiker zu werden. Wir werden gleich über diese Formulierungshelfe reden. Ich stelle euch jetzt eine Frage, die, wenn man in Deutschland aus einer aktivistischen Sicht an Digitalisierung arbeitet, möglicherweise dazu verführt, zwei Stunden lang in mehr oder weniger kohärentes Geschrei zu verfallen. Aber weil wir ja im Chaosradio 271 schon die Vergangenheit beleuchtet haben, würde ich euch bitten, euch kurz zu halten. Wenn ich frage, es gibt jetzt diese Formulierungshilfe, es gibt jetzt möglicherweise bald eine neue Bundesregierung. Was sind denn die größten Baustellen? Und um das vielleicht im Rahmen zu halten, jeder von euch nur eine. Anna, die größte digitale Infrastrukturbaustelle für die neue Bundesregierung?
Eine.
Es darf eine große sein, aber bitte nur eine.
Ich glaube einfach Digitalisierung und IT-Sicherheit und all diese Dinge nicht immer nur so als das machen wir danach, nachdem wir das gemacht haben, was wir eigentlich machen wollen zu denken, sondern einfach auch die gesamte Denke zu ändern und das nicht mehr als aufpfropfen zu sehen, sondern einfach als Gesamtpaket.
Na ja, wenn ich mir überlege, welche Probleme so angesprochen werden in der Formulierungshilfe, läuft das für mich eigentlich alles auf das gleiche Urproblem oder Grundproblem hinaus und das ist die Mangel der Expertise, um überhaupt solche guten Entscheidungen zu treffen in den Entscheidungsgremien, in der Bundesregierung, dort, wo Entscheidungen über neue Verträge getroffen werden oder wohin die Finanzierung geht. Und das ist, glaube ich, für mich die größte übergreifende Baustelle, die ich sehe.
Das geht eigentlich in dieselbe Richtung. Es fehlt an einer grundsätzlichen digitalen Bildung, die in allen Belangen dazu führt, dass auch Menschen damit kukketieren, dass sie im Digitalen nicht wirklich zu Hause sind. Und das muss, glaube ich, insofern umgebaut werden, dass auch für die Generation, die jetzt als Silver Server am Start wäre, selbstverständlich ist, dass man einmal brauchbares Netz zu Hause hat, dass man sich mit Computern auskennt, dass man weiß, auf welche Links man klicken soll und welche nicht, und dass man Smartcards souverän selber benutzt, ohne Besuch von irgendwelchen Hackern aus dem Ausland auf seinem Rechner tagtäglich zu haben.
Also, also Auskennung eigentlich in jeder Hinsicht. Jetzt, ich hatte mir überlegt, ob wir überhaupt drüber sprechen, aber jetzt, wo ihr angesprochen habt, dass das zentrale Problem ein Kompetenzproblem mehr oder weniger ist, muss ich es doch fragen. Weil es gibt ja in der öffentlichen Diskussion, auch in der Medien-Diskussion, ist ja eine Frage ganz reichhaltig diskutiert worden, die in der Formulierungshilfe überhaupt gar nicht vorkommt. Und das ist die nach Ja oder Nein brauchen wir ein Digitalministerium. Anna, warum? Warum brichst du gleich ein Lachen aus? Ist das eine relevante Diskussion?
Nein, ich glaube, es ist eine Scheindiskussion. Ich glaube, es ist auch so eine Zombie-Diskussion, die halt eigentlich immer wieder kommt, wenn man halt irgendwie versucht, nicht einen Schuldigen zu finden, sondern irgendwas, das es vielleicht besser macht und das man irgendwie neu machen kann. Und ich glaube, es ist ja einfach nur so dieses Ding. Ich habe jetzt das Gefühl, wenn man jetzt ein Digitalministerium irgendwie einrichtet, dann macht man das, weil irgendjemand noch einen Posten braucht. Und am Ende hat man doch nichts gewonnen, weil es ja irgendwie nicht darum geht, dass das Thema Digitalisierung zu wenig stellen wird. Ich glaube, über den Punkt sind wir weit hinaus. Und ich frage mich auch, wie will man denn so was besetzen? Und wenn man jetzt ein Digitalministerium besetzen will und es schaffen würde, eine Expertise reinzukriegen, wo ist dann die Expertise in den ganzen anderen Ministerien, die das betrifft? Und was soll dieses Digitalministerium eigentlich machen? Ich finde, dadurch macht man das Problem. Weil diese vermeintliche Spaltung von das ist jetzt irgendwie digital und das ist der ganze Rest noch viel, viel schlimmer. Und das wäre einfach, ich glaube, extrem kontraproduktiv.
Ist das der Grund, warum ihr das ausgelassen habt in der Formulierungshilfe?
Na, mein Lieblingszitat, was das zusammenfasst, ist ja, vor 30 Jahren war man was Besonderes, wenn man was mit Computern macht. Heute ist man was Besonderes, wenn man nichts mit Computern macht. Deswegen, wenn das, was du da tust, irgendwie in einem öffentlichen Amt nicht irgendwie mit Digitalisierung zu tun hat, hast du wahrscheinlich die letzten 20 Jahre Entwicklung verpennt. Das heißt, es muss alles durchdringen. Wir haben ein sehr mächtiges Werkzeug, um sämtliche Interaktion zwischen Behörden, Interaktion von Behörde mit dem Bürger, Aufbau von Projekten, Verwaltung von Projekten zu gestalten. Wer dort die Chancen der Digitalisierung nicht auch der Verwaltungstätigkeit benutzt und das delegiert auf irgendein Ministerium, was dann irgendwie Digitalisierung machen soll, bloß man selber nicht, haben wir nichts gewonnen. Deswegen ein eigenes Digitalisierungsministerium ist kontraproduktiv und sorgt nur dafür, dass man im Zweifel kompetente Personen irgendwo da hinschieht, wo sie am allerwenigsten konstruktiv bewegen können.
Also was ich da sozusagen im Subtext höre, ist, wenn es ein Digitalisierungsministerium gäbe, wäre das aber ein schwarzes Loch für die wenigen Leute, die sich jetzt schon mit IT auskennen in der Politik. Das ist auch so eine Art Senke, eine Art Kompetenzsenke. Ein Digitalministerium wäre also eine Kompetenzsenke für die Digitalisierung in Deutschland.
Ja, nicht nur eine Senke, sondern auch so ein Gerangel. Ich meine, wir haben doch jetzt schon genug gerangelt. Es gibt doch unglaublich viele Cyber-TM Gremien, es gibt unglaublich viele Digitalisierungsgremien. Und ich frage mich, brauchen wir wirklich noch eins und dann weiß niemand mehr, wer jetzt wirklich wofür zuständig ist?
Ja, ich sehe das eh nicht. Also ich finde es auch ein bisschen problematisch, da wieder etwas Neues auf ein existierendes Problem darauf zu setzen, weil in seiner Grundstruktur wird daran nichts geändert. Ich bin nur immer ein bisschen vorsichtig. Ich stimme zu, da gehen wir eigentlich schon direkt in die Formulierungshilfe des CCCs. Da steht ja auch drin, dass diese Kompetenzen aufgebaut werden sollen. Die Abschaffung des digitalen Anaheimverbetentums. Ich glaube, es gibt da ein paar Modellprojekte. Ich denke da beispielsweise an das Transparenzgesetz in Hamburg, wo das auch durchdacht wurde. Ich habe jetzt keine Evaluation davon gesehen. Aber natürlich muss man sich Gedanken dazu machen, wie kann man denn so eine Fortbildung, wie kann man denn so ein Upskilling in den Behörden eigentlich wirksam machen? Was ja oft passiert ist, dass neue Bedürfnisse oder neue Forderungen an Behörden herangetragen werden, so ziemlich jede Woche, und dann stehen sie vor dem Problem, dass sie zu wenig Ressourcen haben. Also ich glaube, da muss man schon nochmal darüber nachdenken, wie kann sowas eigentlich gut aussehen? Das ist das erste, was ich dazu denke. Und das zweite ist, ich weiß auch gar nicht, ob das bei allen Punkten so angemessen ist, diese Expertise auch intern aufzubauen. Ich glaube, bei einigen Sachen spezifischer, bei der zweiten Formulierung in der Formulierungshilfe, wo es darum geht, Projekte zu evaluieren, das ist ein großes Bedürfnis. Aber da frage ich mich, muss das denn wirklich innerhalb der Behörden liegen? Oder schafft man da nicht wieder die gleichen Probleme? Oder müsste das nicht vielleicht sogar was externes sein? Ein externes Gremium, ein unabhängiges, das nicht mit dem gleichen IT-Dienstleister seit 20 Jahren zusammenarbeitet und deswegen vielleicht auch etwas neutralere Entscheidungen treffen kann. Genau, das ist so das, was mir da instant in den Kopf kommt.
Da möchte ich da gleich mal einhaken. Bevor wir dann wieder zurückkommen, wie wir vielleicht sozusagen die Leute, die im Ministerien arbeiten, auch noch kompetenter kriegen. Nämlich, wenn du sagst, es muss ein externes Kontrollgremium geben. Die Tatsache, dass bis heute externe Kräfte bei der Digitalisierung in der Politik so eine große Rolle gespielt haben, der haben wir es ja zu verdanken, dass alle irgendwie Aktivistinnen die Augen rollen, wenn auch nur irgendjemand Blockchain oder KI oder Big Data sagt. Wenn du jetzt sagst, es müsste so eine externe Struktur geben, wie schafft man das denn aber, dass dann in dieser externen Struktur die so eine Evaluierung vornehmen kann, dass da dann Leute sitzen, die eben nicht... Irgendjemand hat das in die Vorbereitung geschrieben, die ja eben nicht IT-Glücksritter sind, sondern die halt wirklich Ahnung, Plan und vor allen Dingen das Wohl der Gesellschaft im Auge haben.
Naja, ich glaube, dass ja bisher die Expertise, wer hat denn da beratend sicherlich solche mit einem bestimmten kommerziellen Interesse? Ich glaube, da gab es keine unabhängige Beratung. Wenn man sich die Verträge mal anschaut, beispielsweise für die Corona-Warn-App, da waren vielleicht auch so ein paar Red Flags drin, die man hätte erkennen können. Ich glaube auch, dass es viel, ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht, aber ich habe immer das, wenn ich mir so angucke, was da passiert ist. Letztens hat das glaube ich Thorsten Schulter ganz schön gesagt, dass es nichts anderes Digital-Schrott, fast jedes Digitalthema, das unsere Regierung in den letzten 16 Jahren angepackt hat, ist Schrott. Genau, das ist eine ziemlich traurige Bestandsaufnahme, aber ich denke, das stimmt ein Stück weit, aber ich glaube, man muss sich die Frage stellen, welche Expertise wurde denn da zur Rate gezogen? Wer hat denn das beraten? Vielleicht die Leute, die eh am Ende des Tisches sitzen. Ich glaube, dass es da schon interessant wäre, darüber nachzudenken, mal wirklich ganz offen, wie könnte denn so ein unabhängiges Gremium aussehen? Genau, weil ich habe so das Gefühl, was ich oft sehe, man sieht das wie so ein Autounfall, man kann den nicht aufhalten, ich habe das Gefühl, da spielt oft so Verführung eine Rolle. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr oder so, es ist halt verführerisch vieles, so neue Systeme, so das Primat des Neuen in den Sondierungspapieren ist wieder von Blockchain-Strategie die Rede und so weiter und so fort. Also da wir so in den entscheidenden Positionen, wo Entscheidungen getroffen werden, da fehlte vielleicht die Expertise, um dann auch in den entscheidenden Situationen sagen zu können, vielleicht brauchen wir das auch nicht.
Aber ich habe das Gefühl, du hast jetzt noch mal zu sagen, ich will dich erklären, was meine Frage war, aber wie sieht die Antwort aus? Also wie schaffen wir genau das, was du forderst?
Naja, also ich könnte mir schon vorstellen, dass es auch ein unabhängiges Gremium geben könnte mit Expertinnen aus der Zivilgesellschaft, aus den Communities und da auch einfach mal mutig so ein paar mehr Schulterschlüsse herstellen, die also verteilt Expertise, meine Wegen auch teilweise aus der Wirtschaft, aber eben nicht nur. Und es ist jetzt nicht so, als würden nicht lauter Leute in den Staatlöchern stehen, die auch Lust haben, das mitzugestatten.
Aber gibt's da Ideen, also das ist ja sozusagen diese Krux. Es gibt einerseits diese Leute, die das können und die das auch wollen. Und andererseits gibt es halt die Menschen, wie hast du es gerade gesagt, die am langen Ende des Tisches sitzen. Und so wie kriegt man jetzt die anderen sozusagen auch dazu, wie kriegt man die Politik in Zukunft dazu, darauf zu hören?
Ich kann ja ganz kurz nochmal meine Erfahrung auch in der Zusammenarbeit mit solchen Behörden und der Politik, wenn die Aufträge vergeben, hast du tatsächlich auch selber, wir nennen es Project Ownership, die du selber trägst. Das heißt normalerweise hast du ja irgendeinen Verhandlungspartner auf der anderen Seite, der den Projektfortschritt mit dir begutachtet, am Anfang absteckt, was die Ziele sind und am Ende überprüft, ob tatsächlich auch das Verlangte geleistet ist. Früher hat man sowas Pflichtenheft genannt. Inzwischen ist das ja durch die ganze agile Programmierung ein bisschen aufgeweicht, was man wann festmachen muss mit wem. Erdgeist, Erdgeist.
Du kannst nicht Pflichtenheft und agile Programmierung sagen, ohne es zu erklären. Das ist dir doch vorher klar gewesen, oder?
Alter Schwede, ein Pflichtenheft...
Nur ganz kurz den Unterschied.
Also grob im Pflichtenheft hast du auf der anderen Seite schon Kompetenz, wie wenn du eine Autobahn baust, das ist Pflichtenheft. Wir machen irgendwie nach Regulatorien X, Y und Z so und so 4 km Autobahn, wird abgenommen und ihr kennt den Drill, seit 50 Jahren oder seit 100 Jahren baut ihr Autobahnen. Agile Programmierung ist dann eher der Vergleich, wir gucken erstmal, ihr planiert erstmal und dann schauen wir, ob das überhaupt geeignet ist und dann machen wir die zweite Schicht drüber und wenn das alles nicht klappt, dann können wir doch schnell zwischendurch abbrechen und die Straße weiter links bauen oder so. Das ist der grobe Unterschied. Aber diese Projektplanungs- und Begleitungskompetenz ist in den Behörden quasi nicht vorhanden. Die musst du selber mitbringen. Das heißt, du setzt dich da mit dem Kunden an der Stelle, für mich als Programmierersicht, setzt du dich mit deinem Kunden hin und quatscht ihm gleich an die Backe, was du glaubst, was er haben möchte. Du hast also die Aufgabe, gleichzeitig mit ihm daherzugehen und mit ihm quasi grüne Wiese zu beackern. Und wenn es nicht irgendwelche Off-the-shelf-Lösungen sind, von denen der Kunde schon Ahnung hat, dann arbeitest du mit dem das live aus und kannst auch selber reinschreiben, was dann am Ende die Konventionalsstrafen sein sollten, wenn es nicht klappt, und dann arbeitest du aus, was für dich am wenigsten Arbeit macht. Und während ich jetzt als Programmierer, mir ist es peinlich, meinen Projektpartner übers Ohr zu hauen, aber ich hätte da wirklich reichlich Gelegenheit, weil einfach den meisten Behörden und auch in der Politik die Erfahrung, wie man Digitalprojekte begleitet, wie man überprüft, ob die noch on track sind, diese Erfahrung ist da einfach nicht vorhanden. Und die könnte aber einfach für so einen Behördenmitarbeiter zwingende Weiterbildung werden. Wir haben im Informatikunterricht, also im Informatikstudium, haben wir eine Vorlesung gehabt, in dem es genau um IT-Projektmanagement gab, so im Rahmen der Ringvorlesung. Da wurde einfach das erklärt, da wurden erklärt, woran man das erkennt, wie man das plant, wie man das abnimmt.
Ich habe das Gefühl, wir verlassen gerade die Strecke, dass wir klären, wie kriegt man eine externe Evaluierungskompetenz hin, sondern gerade wieder in die Ministerien reingehen. Kann das sein?
Ich weiß gar nicht. Ja, natürlich, du kriegst ja so eine externe Kompetenz. Da hilft dir nichts, wenn da alle zwei Monate jemand kommt und auf den Tisch schaut, sondern du musst eine grundsätzliche Erfahrung immer schon in den...
Stopp, stopp. Ich habe versprochen, und wir machen das auch noch, dass wir darüber sprechen, wie wir das Innenleben der Ministerien umgestalten können. Aber ich wollte erst mal mit dem anfangen, was Fiona gesagt hat, die ja meinte, man darf das nicht nur im internen belassen, sondern es braucht sozusagen, es muss dafür gesorgt werden, dass die Leute, die von externen Beratungen antragen, nicht nur von den Leuten bestimmt werden, die so...
Da wollte ich gerade zu kommen, ich muss dir diesen Bogen spannen, weil die brauchen ja auch... Das ist ja ein großes schwarzes Loch, was da fehlt. Weil jetzt sind wir fast dabei, wenn der Fahrdienst von der Bundestagsverwaltung zum Beispiel, die haben da irgendwie ein bisschen Ahnung von Autos, aber die dürfen sich trotzdem nicht selber ihren TÜV ausstellen. Also es gibt da in der Behörde jemanden, der kann da mit Autos, der repariert die vielleicht auch, aber am Ende müssen die immer wieder vorgestellt werden bei der externen Organisation. Das heißt, du kriegst externe Expertise, nicht daher... die dann nicht die ganze Zeit sich die Hand auf den Stirn klopft, was da irgendwie alles kaputt ist, wenn nicht schon irgendwie einen Ansprechpartner mit einer basalen Kompetenz, mit einer Grundkompetenz, wie die Nomenklatur ist, was die Worte sind, die man benutzen muss, um so ein IT-Projekt zu managen. Das kriegst du überhaupt erst gar nicht drauf. Du kriegst diese Kommunikation zwischen Behörden und zwischen der Politik und einer externen Entität nicht hin, wenn nicht einmal das allerunterste Niveau geregelt ist. Und dafür brauchst du dann immer einen Ansprechpartner, der dann die Checklisten abgleicht. Und da fehlt es gerade minimal dran. Und wenn du dann so weit bist, dann kannst du gucken, ob du genau wie mit TÜV und DEKRA im Autobereich, ob du dann so Organisationen wie in Eko oder Bitkom dazu bekommst oder vielleicht jetzt mal hier die IHK, die potenziell ja solche Kompetenz mitbringen könnten, die dann eben bestimmen, wer am Ende drauf gucken und evaluieren darf. Aber die haben ja üblicherweise auch Probleme, Ansprechpartner zu finden, die ein bisschen Kompetenz mitbringen, um sich da überhaupt auf Augenhöhe unterhalten zu können.
Ich bin ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen verwirrt. Weil was ich von Fiona gehört habe ist, wir brauchen so eine Expertise. Die Expertise muss divers zusammengesetzt sein, im Sinne von nicht nur Wirtschaft, sondern auch eben Leute, die das Ganze schon irgendwie netzpolitisch betreuen und vielleicht auch aus einer anderen Ecke draufkommen. Und was ich von dir gerade, Fiona stimmt das?
Ja, ich glaube, es ist auch ein bisschen müßig, da jetzt zu sehr ins Detail zu gehen, zu überlegen, wie sowas aussehen könnte in der Praxis. Es könnte beispielsweise, wenn es eine Auftragsvergabe gibt für ein größeres technisches Projekt ab einer bestimmten Summe, gibt es einen Rat von Leuten, die zusammengezogen werden aus Zivilgesellschaft, meiner Meinung nach aus der Industrie, die dann zusammenkommen und ebenfalls ihren Senf dazugeben. So primitiv könnte es im Grunde genommen aussehen. Und das gibt es in meinen Augen bisher noch nicht. Aber vielleicht gibt es da auch ausgefeitere Formate oder Modelle, wo sowas was schon mal gemacht wurde. Aber im Endeffekt ist es auch immer eine Frage von, muss man da glaube ich schauen? Und dafür bin ich aber nicht die Expertin zu sagen, wie sowas aufgebaut sein kann.
Genau, ich will auch gar nicht genau wissen, wie das Gremium aussehen müsste. Sondern was mich interessiert an der Stelle ist nur, wie man sicherstellen kann. Also wenn was Erdgeist gerade gesagt hat, wenn eine Bitkom sozusagen das stellen würde, eine Bitkom ist ja letztlich ein Wirtschaftsverein. Ich weiß nicht sozusagen, ob da die Zivilgesellschaft im Sinne von nicht hauptsächlich profitorientiert denkende Menschen natürlich zum Zuge kämen. Und meine Frage ist nicht so sehr, sagt mal ganz konkret, wie so ein Konsortium aussehen könnte, sondern wie kann sichergestellt werden, dass die Zivilgesellschaft, ich nehme jetzt einfach mal die als Schlagwort, dass die Zivilgesellschaft tatsächlich zu Wort kommt. Und zwar immer wieder und zwar nicht nur als Token. Also nicht nur SAP, Telekom, keine Ahnung, was es noch alles gibt, Google, Microsoft, Facebook und dann ein Vertreter der Zivilgesellschaft, sondern mit einer gleichberechtigten präsenten Stimme.
Ich glaube, man darf die einfach nicht als Feind sehen. Ich finde, wenn wir jetzt irgendwie über Regierungs- und Verwaltungsprojekte reden, muss man eigentlich schon froh sein, dass die sogenannte Zivilgesellschaft überhaupt noch mit einem redet, so wie man sie in den letzten Jahren behandelt hat. Also wenn man gerade so eine Hackerin und Hacker, die in ihrer Freizeit irgendwie gucken, wo vielleicht die Sicherheitsprobleme von irgendwelchen Sachen sind, und dann kriegen sie dann eine Anzeige irgendwie an den Hals. Und ich glaube, da muss man einfach mal generell überlegen, wie man mit den Leuten umgeht. Ich meine, es ist die eine Sache, sie zu fragen. Dann kommt irgendwie das Level vielleicht, irgendwie die Antwort auf diese Frage ernst zu nehmen. Und nicht nur so als, uiuiui, wir haben jetzt eine zivilgesellschaftliche Konnotation gemacht, wir haben jetzt unsere Pflicht getan. Und dann eben auch quasi aktiv an seinem Umgang mit den Leuten zu arbeiten und sie eben nicht mehr als Feinde wahrzunehmen, die einem eins reinwürgen wollen, sondern eben als Leute, die oft ehrenamtlich einfach die Probleme aufzeigen und das nicht machen, weil sie Böses tun wollen oder eine böse Zusammenrottung sind, sondern weil sie eben wollen, dass es besser läuft.
Spielt da Geld auch eine Rolle oder geht es tatsächlich vor allen Dingen darum, dass gerade diese ehrenamtliche Arbeit auch gesehen und gewertschätzt und nicht strafverfolgt wird?
Na ja, es muss nicht immer unbedingt alles bezahlt werden. Auf der anderen Seite kannst du eben, wenn das kontinuierlich da sein soll und die Zivilgesellschaft gehört werden soll für alle möglichen Projekte, die da ankommen, dann hast du das Problem, dass es dann so zum Halbtagsjob ausartet und dann schon schwer ehrenamtlich zu stemmen ist. Das heißt, da gibt es dann natürlich gleich wieder Begehrlichkeiten, wer da rein kann, und dann gibt es dann wieder großes Gekeile. Dann werden auch wieder die großen Firmen und Institutionen, die üblichen Verdächtigen, versuchen, sich da mit reinzusetzen, um bestimmte Entscheidungen in ihren Sinne zu beeinflussen. Wir hatten in der Vergangenheit so Enquete-Kommissionen, die zu bestimmten Themenschwerpunkten auch die Zivilgesellschaft mit eingeladen und dort befragt hatte. Als es zuletzt irgendwie ein KI hatte und der Bundestag auch eingeladen, alle diversen Stimmen zu hören. Das wäre vielleicht ein Forum. Ansonsten könnten eventuell freiwilligen Räte zusammenkommen, sowas wie im Kontext THW. Es gibt ja auch bestimmte freiwillige Kultur, die organisiert wird. In Deutschland haben wir ja eine lange Tradition, die man bemühen könnte, wie man es schafft, dort Kontinuität herzustellen. Wie man es schafft, auch bei Ausscheiden von einigen, die das eben nicht mehr leisten können aus Gründen, die zu ersetzen. Es gibt da Mittel und Wege, das zu tun. Das will ich jetzt ja auch in Detail nicht ausrollen, wie du schon meintest, dass das ist. Vielleicht, wenn man sich erstmal darauf einigt, dass es eine gute Idee wäre, die Zivilgesellschaft anzuhören, dann kann man von da auf später auch aufbauen.
An dieser Stelle, Entschuldigung, Marcus, dass ich dich unterbreche, an dieser Stelle darauf hinweisen, digitalezivilgesellschaft.org ist ein Zusammenschluss von vielen Organisationen aus der digitalen Zivilgesellschaft, die da auch ein bisschen konkrete Forderungen aufgestellt haben, als wir, und ich glaube auch eine ganz gute Analyse gemacht haben, was notwendig wäre. Kann man auch unterzeichnen?
Das heißt aber sozusagen, um nochmal auf dieses Ehrenamtliche zurückzukommen, da geht es ja nicht so sehr darum, die konkrete Arbeit zu bezahlen, sondern eher darum, auch in die Strukturen zu investieren, die so eine ehrenamtliche Arbeit überhaupt möglich machen. Oder ist das jetzt einen Schritt zu weit gedacht?
Die Frustration vielleicht auch zu minimieren, wenn du das formalisierst, was du da am Ende erreichen kannst, als jemand dir rechtzeitig nein sagt. Das ist ja das Hauptproblem, dass ich ja auch oft im Bundestag gesessen und meine Meinung angehört wurde. Und dann wurde sie Adapter gelegt und dann wurde damit nichts gemacht. Das heißt, die formale Macht, die dann mein Bedenkenträgertum im Vorfeld hatte, ging gegen null. War einfach so, Zivilgesellschaft wurde angehört, können wir Häkchen dran machen. Gesetz wird trotzdem unter Ignorieren dessen, was da die Sachverständigen gesagt haben, abgenickt. Das heißt, wenn du das irgendwie formalisierst, dass im Vorfeld Zivilgesellschaft angehört werden muss und sich das dann auch irgendwie niederschlägt, dann würde man dieses frustrierende Moment, dass es eh alles umsonst ist, was du da tust und dein einziger Hebel ist vier Jahre später told you, so zu sagen, könntest du schon mal viel ehrenamtliches Engagement wieder aktivieren, was gerade echt rumliegt und teilweise aus Frucht, aber teilweise auch aus den schlechten Erfahrungen der letzten Jahre, sogar Jahrzehnte nicht mehr so.
Aber auf der einen Seite ist ja sozusagen, das ist ja quasi nach dem Ergebnis. Du hast Leute, die machen diese Arbeit und wenn sie diese Arbeit gemacht haben, müssen sie Angst davon haben, wie umgegangen sind. Was ich mich gerade frage ist, ist in Deutschland die Situation, dass Leute diese Arbeit überhaupt machen können, also die Förderung von, ich weiß nicht, von Communities, von Vereinen, von Infrastrukturen. Du hast ja gerade die freiwilligen Traditionen der Deutschen angesprochen. Gibt es sie im Digitalen schon? Also natürlich gibt es die, aber gibt es sie schon genug? Oder müsste da auch noch was gemacht werden, dass man sozusagen, ich weiß nicht, Hex... Also auf ein ganz konkretes, plumpes Beispiel, müssen mehr Hex-Bases gefördert werden oder so. Oder sozusagen abstrakt gefragt, wird die Community, wird diese Gemeinschaft, wird dieses Ehrenamt überhaupt genug ermöglicht in Deutschland?
Ich denke, mit der nationalen Vergleich ist Deutschland einfach echt weit vorne. Wenn wir uns die Kongresse angucken, wo wir ein Viertel derer, die da hinkommen, freiwillig als Engel helfen, ich denke, das ist einfach selbstverständlich in der Hacker-Kultur und in der weiteren Netz-Community ist immer so ein großes Wort.
Das, wenn man kann, dass man das dann macht, das ist mir schon klar. Aber es geht mir um dieses Wenn man kann.
Ja, siehst du, die stehen alle in Tappeln mit den Füßen. Es gibt da irgendwie die Kids machen hier zerforschung.org, gucken sich das an, jetzt unabhängig vom CCC. Es gibt viele Huxbases, die irgendwie auch fern von CCC Einfluss wie aufgemacht werden, die dort sich ehrenamtlich engagieren, um genau Bildung im Digitalen weiterzugeben, die selber forschen, die selber Dinge tun. Es gibt einfach so viel Kompetenz, die da rumliegt. Und wenn sie kanalisiert werden könnte, würden sie das auch jederzeit tun. Die meisten, die sich diese Kompetenzen und die sich Bildung angeeignet haben, freuen sich die Platze danach, die irgendwie sinnstiftend anbringen zu dürfen. Und das als Regierung oder das als Gesellschaft nicht zu kanalisieren, das nicht zu benutzen, ist traurig.
Ja, ich muss dem zustimmen und auch das, was Anna vorher gesagt hatte. Es gibt ja eine Civic Tech Community, die hat auch ein paar Überschneidungen auf jeden Fall mit den Hackspace oder Hacking-Community, aber ist auch noch mal teilweise noch mal anders aufgestellt. Und da gibt es auch noch mal viele Kompetenzen aus der Stadtentwicklung, meinetwegen auch aus dem Design, Architektur und so weiter. Es war damals mit denen, da gibt es ja immer noch die Open Knowledge Labs im Projekt Coffee Germany, die wirklich in zahlreichen Städten sich hinsetzen, überlegen, was kann man denn mit Daten machen. Aber, so wie Anna vorher auch gesagt hatte, wenn man sich anschaut, was denen so unter anderem passiert ist in den letzten Jahren. Ich denke da an das Projekt Kleine Anfragen.de, das eingestellt werden müsste, weil das offene Parlamentsdokumentationssystem so oft umgestellt wurde, dass es ehrenamtlich einfach nicht mehr zu schaffen war. Und da gab es wirklich einen Mangel an Zuhören, an Ernstnehmen, an wirklich strukturell einbinden, was wirklich schade ist. Und es gibt da so ein komisches, verrücktes Verhältnis oder irgendwie sehr widersprüchlich, dass einerseits Ehrenamt überhaupt nicht gefördert wird, andererseits die Bundesregierung oder die lokalen Verwaltungen es auch selber überhaupt nicht hinkriegen, solche kleinen digitalen Projekte umzusetzen, auch wenn sie es sich vornehmen. Also da ist wirklich strukturell so einiges im Argen. Ich muss aber auch nochmal sagen, nochmal darauf hinweisen, dass digitale Zivilgesellschaft da ein paar konkrete Forderungen aufgestellt hat, wie sowas aussehen kann, dass erstmal gemeinsame Digitalmission entwickelt werden müsste. Dass dann paritätisch besetzte runde Tische stattfinden müssten. Dass es eine Quote geben muss bei solchen Gesetzesentscheidungen, beispielsweise wie viel Zivilgesellschaft dabei sein muss. Also da gibt es eigentlich auch ein paar konkrete Ideen schon. Das heißt, es liegt eigentlich alles auf dem Tisch. Es ist jetzt nicht so, als wenn das ein Geheimnis wäre oder keine Anleitung vorliegen würde. Frage ist halt nur, ob der politische Wille jetzt da ist.
Okay, also das Problem sozusagen, das bei allem, was wir jetzt besprochen haben, was ihr seht, ist immer, eigentlich gibt es schon in Ansätzen oder auch in Ausformulierungen eine Lösung, aber sie wird halt nicht gehört. Und dann kommen wir halt tatsächlich jetzt zu diesem Punkt, auf dem Erdgeist, der mal ganz erfolgreich rumgebohrt hat, nämlich die, wie kommt die Kompetenz in die Ministerien? Oder andersrum gefragt, es gibt gerade Menschen, die arbeiten daran, eine neue Regierung zu werden. Wie können die dafür sorgen, dass das passiert?
Ich glaube, es hat extrem viele Gründe. Das, was öffentlich immer gesagt wird, ist natürlich, wir können die ganzen Leute mit der IT-Kompetenz ja nicht bezahlen, weil wir dürfen ja nur so wie im öffentlichen Dienst bezahlen. Aber ehrlich gesagt glaube ich nicht, dass das das größte Problem ist. Ich glaube, das größte Problem ist einfach, wenn ich mir überlegen würde, ob ich ernsthaft für ein Ministerium arbeiten wollen würde, dass irgendwie oftmals einfach eine widersprüchliche Politik verfolgt, wenn man jetzt gerade so in den ganzen Innenbereich guckt. Ich meine, es ist halt schwierig, sich irgendwie mit einem reinen Gewissen irgendwie in einem BMI zu engagieren und zu wissen, vielleicht mache ich da jetzt ein ganz tolles Digitalprojekt. Aber auf der anderen Seite gibt es dann irgendwie Staatsdrojaner und diese ganze komische Sicherheit trotz Verschlüsselung und Sicherheit irgendwie mit Verschlüsselungspolitik. Für sowas will man vielleicht auch nicht arbeiten. Und dann kriegt man vielleicht auch einfach die Leute nicht rangezogen, die Prinzipien haben.
Aber marzynisch gefragt, geht es darum, dass man Leute hat, die Prinzipien haben oder geht es vor allen Dingen auch darum, dass es da Leute gibt, die Ahnung haben?
Na im besten Fall beides. Also Leute mit Ahnung und ohne Prinzipien sind ziemlich gefährlich. Vielleicht ist das nicht das, was man haben will.
Also ich kann mir tatsächlich nicht vorstellen, dass es in Deutschland möglich ist, in jeder Behörde einen eigenen Brandschutz beauftragt, einen eigenen Datenschutz beauftragt, einen eigenen Betriebsschutz beauftragt zu haben, aber nicht möglich ist, durchzusetzen, dass auch eine Mindestkompetenz in jeder Abteilung besteht, irgendwie mit IT Projektvergabe oder zumindest irgendwie eine grundsätzliche digitale Bildung und das wie auch weiter zu tragen. Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass man das nicht einfach erlassen kann, dass eine gewisse Weiterbildungspflicht im Digitalen für mindestens einen Mitarbeiter, der es dann in jede Abteilung reinträgt, dass das nicht möglich ist. Und ich glaube, da fängt einmal für mich digitales Alphabetisierungsprogramm an, dass man eben nicht mehr kockettieren darf, dass ach, wir wissen ja alle, diese Computer sind zu kompliziert und wir ärgern uns jeden zweiten Tag darüber, dass der so langsam ist und dass die Masken eh alle nicht funktionieren, sondern wenn sich alle Mitarbeiter darüber beschweren, dann geht man da hin und sagt dem Dienstleister nochmal mit der Axt auf den Tisch, jetzt mach mal ordentlich oder, naja, aber das ist das Schlimmste, was mir in den letzten 16 Jahren der alten Kanzlerschaft, der Bundeskanzlerin da passiert ist, dass die sich ernsthaft dieses Neuland-Zitat, dass sie sich ganz ernsthaft hinstellt, was auf menschliche Art und Weise vielleicht nachvollziehbar ist, sich da irgendwie dem Wähler ein wenig so jovial näher zu bringen, aber auf der anderen Seite eine Bagotterklärung vor dem Herrn Und vor allem ein Template für alle anderen, wenn sogar die Bundeskanzlerin als Naturwissenschaftlerin mit einem Doktor der Chemie, wenn selbst die es nicht hinbekommt, sich da irgendwie mit diesen Computern da souverän auseinanderzusetzen. Ach, was sollen wir denn dann machen? Und das war so der Schlag in die Magengrube, dass dann können wir eigentlich als Gesellschaft auch, wenn das da unser Credo ist, dann können wir uns einfach musealisieren.
Aber das ist doch jetzt auch schon eine ganze Weile her, dass das gesagt wurde, und da hätte man ja auch sagen können, ja gut, eigentlich ist der erste Schritt zur Besserung oder nicht?
Nein, wäre es nicht so ein augenzwinkendes Kockettieren gewesen, mit einem, ja geht euch doch auch allen so, oder?
Für mich waren es Flugtaxis, für mich waren Flugtaxis das Schlimmste. Und dass es einfach keine Folgensanktionen oder Konsequenzen hatte, dass jemand überhaupt mit dieser bescheuerten Idee um die Ecke kommt. Naja, sorry, ich habe euch unterbrochen.
Das ist genau, was Marcus vorhin meinte, das ist schön, dass du es nochmal bringst. Das ist genau dieses Foto-Opp. Ich glaube, das Zitat, was ich neulich, ich weiß nicht mehr, wer das erzählt hat, aber wenn du als jemand, der von IT Ahnung hat und aus der Zivilgesellschaft kommst, wenn du einen Politiker ansprichst, dann guck da sich an und versuch dich in eine der beiden Kategorien, entweder möchte der jetzt gerade Projektgelder von mir oder ist er eine Photo-Opportunity für mich. Das sind die beiden Kategorien, wie man einsortiert wird. Und so ein Flugtaxi, wenn das am Ende funktioniert wäre für, war das die Dorobär, die das da angebracht hat. Das wäre doch super, dann kann ich später als modernizitätsheischender Politiker, kann ich mich da mit ablichten lassen und werde dann mit dem Erfolg eines hypermodernen Flugtaxi-Programms assoziiert. Aber das, weißt du, IT must be boring again. Das muss einfach genauso wie...
Also ich verstehe, was du meinst, aber vielleicht kannst du das noch mal ein bisschen elaborieren.
Na, so lange die Basics nicht abgefrühstückt sind, so lange wir irgendwelche kaputten oder nicht existenten digitalen Möglichkeiten haben, uns mit Behörden auseinandersetzen, die Behörden selber noch 90er Jahre Technologie benutzen, ist es nicht sinnvoll mit irgendwelchen leuchtenden Blockchain Technologien, ich sage das jetzt bei Blockchain einfach wieder hypermodernste Kryptographie ist, die die allerwenigsten Leute verstehen und das führt dazu, dass man dann einmal Buzzwords durch die Gegend werfen kann und dann scheint als jemand, der etwas modernes da gerade umsitzt. Und das darf einfach nicht mehr so sein, man darf sich da nicht drin sonnen, sondern man muss irgendwie eher derjenige sein, der jetzt wieder ein Infrastrukturprogramm so Schlaglöcher fixen durchgezogen hat. Damit kann man sich nicht groß als der hypermoderne Zampano präsentieren, aber es ist so.
Infrastruktur hat es immer schwer, es geht halt um Prävention und Prävention ist immer ein bisschen schwer zu verkaufen, das will niemand hören, aber es wird ja schon zum nächsten Punkt in der Formulierung, wo ja auch über so Wartung, Pflege, Auditing von Infrastruktur sprecht und für mich ist das wirklich eines der Probleme, die ich identifiziere als einer der Ursachen, warum wir heute da stehen und eine ziemlich marode und so Infrastruktur haben. Und das ist in meinen Augen dieses permanente Fokussieren auf Innovation, das Primat des Neuen und das in vielen Förderinstrumenten, die zur Verfügung stehen, eigentlich fast das technisch gar nicht geht, existierende Projekte zu verbessern, zu updaten, zu warten, zu pflegen. Und Maintenance ist ein Riesenthema in der Open Source Infrastruktur. Und dass das so lange vernachlässigt wurde nach den ganzen warnenden großen Events, zum Beispiel Heartbleed vor etlichen Jahren, dass das verschlafen wurde, fällt uns, glaube ich, gerade auf die Füße, so mein Eindruck. Und wird uns noch, noch viel mehr unschmerzhaft auf die Füße fallen, die nächsten Jahre, wenn wir da nicht langsam mal die Beine in die Hand nehmen.
Ja, und die Parallele sieht man auch, dass auch Hersteller tatsächlich nicht verpflichtet sind, ihre Produkte weiter zu maintainen und zu pflegen. Die werden am Anfang einmal verkauft. Und du kannst üblicherweise den Hersteller nicht in Regress nehmen, wenn er gravierende Sicherheitslücken weiter auf hat. Wenn er Lust hat, gibt er seinen zahlenden oder weiter zahlenden Kunden eventuell irgendwelche Feature-Updates, die dann Sicherheitslücken mal dabei fixen. Aber solange es nicht tatsächlich auf einen Hersteller von Software wieder zurückfällt, wenn den Mox, den er abgelefert hat, dem Kunden zwei Jahre später auf die Füße fällt. Und wir reden ja bei Behörden üblicherweise über Software, die einfach ewig lang halten muss. Dann willst deine Mitarbeiter darauf schulen und die müssen halt mit diesen langweiligen Werkzeugen müssen die dann eine Weile irgendwie klarkommen und dann willst du eigentlich eine gewisse Langzeitstabilität tatsächlich haben und das auch vom Hersteller einfordern müssen. Und der muss dann eben das ermöglichen und es muss die Möglichkeit geben, auf den Hersteller, der angreifbare Software nicht fixt, in einem bestimmten Zeitrahmen muss man auch wieder durchgreifen dürfen. Und wenn die Politik sich entscheidet, Open Source einzusetzen, dann wäre es auch ganz cool, wenn da Programme mit dabei sind, genau die Pflege von diesen Open Source Programmen zu ermöglichen, indem man Infrastruktur macht, indem man vielleicht Konferenzen mit Ressourcen versieht, wo sich dann die Enthusiasten treffen und wo ihnen auch ermöglicht wird, ihre Software ehrenamtlich weiter zu pflegen, wo die Fixes auch eingespielt werden.
Ich finde es sehr witzig, das ist jetzt quasi die Antwort auf eine Frage, die ich glaube ich vor 20 Minuten gestellt hatte. Das ist das, was ich dachte, was du sagst, als ich fragte, geht es darum für die Leute, die sowas ehrenamtlich machen, eine Infrastruktur zu schaffen. Das ist also ein Punkt, der aufgehen soll. Aber das kann man ja immer im Wohlfall fordern. Wie realisierbar ist das denn? Ist das denn, wie sage ich es nicht zynisch, ich verstehe sozusagen, dass das sinnvoll ist. Dass das eine Forderung ist, die im Großen und Ganzen auch logisch folgt. Also wenn man eine Open-Source-Software benutzen will, dann muss die irgendwann irgendjemand schreiben. Damit die irgendwann irgendjemand schreibt, braucht es halt sozusagen eine lebendige Community oder Infrastruktur. Und dann folgt eben das, was du gerade gesagt hast, muss man das so ein bisschen fördern. Aber wird doch nicht alles viel teurer für die Bundesregierung?
Was genau meinst du, wird teurer?
Ja, also wenn ich jetzt, wenn ich jetzt, also ich kaufe, ich versuch's mal, also vielleicht abstrahiere ich zu sehr, aber das klingt ja so, die Bundesregierung kauft in Zukunft keine Software mehr, sondern nutzt Open Source, aber bezahlt dafür Konferenzen. Aber ist das nicht viel teurer als Software zu kaufen?
Naja, wenn du Förderung, öffentliche Förderung von öffentlicher Infrastruktur eine Ausgabe nennen möchtest, ja, dann wird das vielleicht teurer. Aber es gibt, wir alle nutzen Open Source Software. Der Browser, den wir benutzen, das wir hier miteinander gerade sprechen, das baut auf ganz viel Open Source Software auf, das nutzen Behörden, das nutzen Unternehmen. Unternehmen werden dieser Pflicht, da auch ein bisschen was zurückzugeben an Open Source, weil sie es ja teilweise gratis nutzen, darauf ihre eigenen Services aufbauen. Dem kommen sie ein Stück weit nach. Es entstehen so Nach- und Nachförderungen oder sie erlauben ihren Mitarbeitenden in einige Stunden die Woche an Open Source Software zu arbeiten. Aber ich sehe da auf jeden Fall eine Regierung, auch in der Pflicht, weil es ist öffentliche Daseinsvorsorge. Wir alle nutzen diese Infrastruktur, die ist kritisch für das, was wir tun als Gesellschaft miteinander. Wir kommunizieren, wir arbeiten, machen dies, das, vielleicht gucken wir auch einfach irgendwas im Internet. Aber auch das gehört dazu, genauso wie Straßen, Brückenpfeiler, Grundwasser und so weiter und so fort, das muss gefördert werden. Und ich denke schon, dass uns die Zeit davon läuft und das wird noch teurer, wenn da nicht langsam mal ein bisschen die Züge in die Hand genommen werden und das nachhaltig gefördert wird.
Aber ist das sozusagen, muss man das, was du sagst, sozusagen so einsehen oder gibt es da noch eine andere Möglichkeit, um den Leuten, die jetzt gerade in die Macht kommen, schmackhaft zu machen?
Letztlich wird es ja vielleicht auch nicht unbedingt teurer. Vielleicht wird es für einen Moment mal teurer, aber am Ende sparst du dir die ganzen Lizenz-Knebel-Verträge. Du sparst dir diesen ganzen Kram, dass du dann auch teilweise an eine bestimmte Hardware gebunden bist, an eine bestimmte Plattform gebunden bist und dann quasi mehr oder weniger an einem Hersteller einer Plattform hängst und da nicht mehr rauskommst. Das ist ja auch attraktiv aus einer rein egoistischen Perspektive.
Ja, wir nennen das einfach digitale Souveränität. Das ist etwas, was die EU und was auch Deutschland möchten. Das soll für Staaten gelten, das soll auch für Privatpersonen oder Individuen gelten, dass sie freier ihre Entscheidungen treffen können. Ich glaube, so wird ein Schuh draus. Zweitens würde ich denen das Schmack haben und würde mich halt sagen, hey, Deutschland kann diesbezüglich international Vorreiter werden. Das möchte ich aber auch deswegen betonen, damit das nicht in diese Falle tappt, nur in Deutschland zu fördern, sondern das ist natürlich ein internationales Ding. Wir nutzen international Software aus aller Welt, das heißt, da muss auch die Förderung gehen. Und drittens ist natürlich auch viel wirtschaftssinnvoll, das ist quasi Open-Source-Software, das ist so etwas wie eine Ressource, die Wirtschaft nutzt und die liegt da. Die wird einfach genutzt, die wird aber nicht gepflegt und gewartet und geupdated. Das wird so ein Stück weit den Entwicklern, die teilweise, der klassische Random Dude, der Nebraska sitzt und ein unglaublich wichtiges Tool maintains alleine und dann, wenn etwas schiefgeht, lauter Hassmails bekommt. Ich glaube, gestern Homebrew geschehen, der hatte darüber getwittert. Letztlich ist es auch eine Frage für die Wirtschaft.
Eine kleine E-Mail, die wir gar nicht schonen, es gibt einen XKCD-Comic zu diesem Thema. Könnte das bitte verlinkt werden?
Ja, aber Marcus, ich muss da irgendwie nochmal, weißt du, was die Stadt München alleine Microsoft jährlich in den Rachen wirft, dafür könnten wir fünf Kongresse organisieren. Ernsthaft, ich sehe überhaupt nicht das.
Nur um das klarzustellen, du musst ja nicht mich überzeugen, sondern Rot, Gelb und Grün, die gerade ihre Regierungsprogramme schreiben. Das ist ja die Frage. Ich stelle sie ja nur, man wird ja wohl nochmal fragen.
Kannst du dann auch sagen, dass es total nachhaltig ist? Du kannst natürlich auch noch sagen, wenn du irgendwie deine Software einfach weiterführen kannst, wenn das irgendwann nicht mehr für deine Hardware unterstützt, dann musst du den Quatsch einfach nicht wegwerfen, dann hast du auch noch einen Umweltaspekt, dann hast du noch ein Argument. Also letztlich, das ist jetzt nicht so schwer, irgendwie Argumente zu finden und auch die Argumente zu akzeptieren, weil sie liegen ja schon einfach seit Ewigkeiten auf dem Tisch.
Ja und ich glaube, das Problem ist aber auch so ein bisschen das ganze Thema digitale Infrastruktur in Form von Basistechnologien, auch das, deswegen hat es das am Anfang gesagt, lässt sich wieder zurückführen auf einen Mangel des Verständnisses und Sichtbarkeit oder Verständnis davon, dass es diese Basistechnologien überhaupt gibt und dass das Problem ist. Die tauchen immer nur auf, wenn was kaputt geht, dann hast du Hardbleed, dann hast du die Open Source Supply Chain Attacken, die in den letzten Jahren passiert sind.
Du hast jetzt zweimal Hardbleed gesagt, jetzt musst du es erklären, was war nur ganz kurz, damit die Leute, die es nicht wissen...
Oh nein, Erdgeist zu hilf, es war ein Bug in einer unglaublich weit verbreiteten Library in OpenSSL, das glaube ich 2014 ist dieser Bug aufgetreten, das heißt ein Fehler in dieser Library, die allerdings Open Source war, das heißt man hätte reingucken können, aber es wurden keine Ressourcen darauf verwendet, sich das einmal durchzulesen und zu maintain oder zu updaten, abzusichern und es war im Endeffekt ein Fehler oder eine Sicherheitslücke, die wirklich etliche Tausende von Unternehmen und auch Webseiten im Grunde genommen weltweit betroffen hat. Möchte jemand noch korrigieren oder etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, na die hat uns alle betroffen. Sie hat ja im Prinzip sozusagen dafür gesorgt, dass die Verschlüsselung im Browser, also wo ihr das kleine Schloss manchmal seht, dass die sozusagen nicht mehr abhörsicher war und damit war im Prinzip, also für einen kurzen Moment glaube ich sogar alles offen oder relativ viel zumindest.
Ne, es hat Speicher nach Hause geschickt, der Gegenseite, der, also man konnte sich auf deinem Rechner ein bisschen umgucken, wenn man eine verschlüsselte Verbindung mit deinem Rechner aufgebaut hat oder wenn du eine verschlüsselte Verbindung mit der Gegenseite aufgebaut hast, dann waren Teile des Speichers auslesbar. Aber das war von Fiona so großartig zusammengefasst, dass ich gar nicht weiter was dazu sagen wollte.
Das Problem ist natürlich, wir werden uns dieser Basistechnologien bewusst, wenn es ein Problem gibt. Dann denken wir, auf Eier muss man was tun und dann gibt es ein kleines Konsortium und dann werden ein paar Millionen in die Richtung geworfen von Unternehmen. Aber es gibt keine wirklich übergeordnete Strategie, um das mal abzusichern. Aber wir müssen es tun und sonst flieht uns das ganze Ding um die Ohren bald.
Ganz unten anfangen, genau wie Freifunk als Ehrenamt neulich deklariert wurde, einfach Open-Source-Entwicklung sollte sofort die Qualifikationen als ehrenamtliche Betätigung mit abbekommen. So könnte man einfach per Gesetz erlassen. Kost ihn lächeln. Das würde sofort zu einer sichtbaren Aufwertung derer, die das da tun, führen. Weil das glaub ich so ein bisschen noch immer so, ja hier der Nerd mit seiner Pizza auf dem Bauch im Keller ist ja eh nicht so, was der da so rumfrickelt, wahrscheinlich nicht vom großen Wert. Das ist glaube ich gerade noch so das gesellschaftliche Bild von dem, was Open-Source-Projekte sind, aber das ist in Wirklichkeit teilweise professioneller als an ihrem Dayjob arbeitende Menschen sind, die das, die Open-Source-Projekte abliefern. Das Bild ist noch nicht in der Gesellschaft durchgedrungen, wenn man einfach mal sagt, es ist ein ehrenamtliches Projekt, was du da tust im Sinne von förderungswürdiges Ehrenamt, mit allen steuerlichen Begünstigungen, die der Staat da irgendwie auch noch gewähren kann für die Zeit, die du dafür aufwendest. Es wäre ja mit wenig Aufwand könnte man dort viel in die Community auch an Hochachtung wieder zurücktragen und ihnen zeigen, dass es wertgeschätzt wird.
Habt ihr eigentlich mal kurz, oder habt ihr schon mal geguckt, was die derzeitigen KoalitionspartnerInnen dazu sagen? Weil ich stell mir gerade so die FDP vor. Also hier der Staat fördert eine Infrastruktur, eine Community, die dafür sorgt, dass mächtige Software einfach jedem zur Verfügung steht. Das ist doch Kommunismus.
Nee, das ist das Externalisieren von Kosten. Das mögen die doch.
Aber kommt von dem, was ihr gesagt habt in den Sondierungspapiergesprächen, also von dem, was man stand heute, wir nehmen am 28. Oktober auf, Weiß.
Na, da steht Agil drin. Also die Verwaltung soll auf jeden Fall agiler werden. Das Sondierungspapier ist halt auch so wolkig, dass man sich da alles reindenken kann, was man will. Also ich glaube momentan lässt sich das nicht sagen. Und die sind ja dieses Mal ein bisschen diskreter als letztes Mal. Ich glaube, es ist extrem schwer jetzt abzusehen, ob aus Teilen dieser blooming Formulierungen dann wirklich irgendwas folgt, was die Mensch spricht oder auch nicht. Ich glaube gerade könnte es einfach noch beides sein. Man kann seine Hoffnung reinprojizieren, aber auch seine größten Ängste, glaube ich.
Hört ihr eigentlich diese Blätter? Ich habe das Sondierungspapier vor mir.
Ausgedruckt? Könntest du mir das schnell faxen?
Ich habe schon auf Twitter drüber geschrieben und gefragt, was eine angemessene Strafe ist dafür. Vielleicht mich einfach selber mit dem Druckerkabel hauen oder so. Aber das Recht, das ist alles sehr blumig formuliert. Aber tatsächlich muss ich sagen, ich habe jetzt nicht alle Wahlprogramme gelesen. Ich habe sie ein bisschen überflogen, muss schon sagen. Ich sage es einfach mal, dass da schon bei der FDP, was ich gesehen hatte, und auch bei den Grünen ein paar gute Sachen drin stehen, die ich jetzt so vielleicht auch nicht unbedingt erwartet hätte zum Thema Digitalisierung.
Kannst du nur ein Beispiel für alle, die gerade unglaublich die Augen aufreißen, nennen?
Naja, zum Beispiel, also sie haben ja schon so Schutz der Bewahrtsphäre, steht da relativ groß drin und dann haben sie aber auch ziemlich fett reingeschrieben. So jetzt bin ich durcheinander gekommen, gleich schneide ich mich bestimmt am Papier. Opferschutz bei Straftaten im Internet stärken, da schreiben sie ziemlich viel so zum Thema Hasspostings, dass sie dazu was machen. Also es gibt da so ein paar Sachen, wo ich sagen würde, na gut, kann man jetzt nicht direkt, also es zeigt einfach so ein bisschen, da saß jemand, der sich ein bisschen mehr damit auseinandergesetzt hat.
Was mir so Mut gemacht hat, war, in den letzten Jahren waren ja diese Arbeitsgruppen immer von Leuten besetzt, die dort frisch vom SAP kamen und die bei T-Systems gearbeitet haben und dieses Jahr, die Koalitionsverhandlungsrunden sind ja so in unterschiedliche Themen kategorisiert und da, wo es um digitale Innovation und digitale Infrastruktur gibt, da sind die Chefverhandler, so Malte Spitz von den Grünen. Das ist so einmal, ich will jetzt keine einzelnen Parteien, wie bei den Grünen Klelen loben, aber der Malte Spitz, der bin ich mir ziemlich sicher, dass der nicht ins Lexikon gucken muss, um nachzuschauen, was Digitalisierung heißt. Und Jan-Philipp Albrecht sitzt da für die Grünen und bei der FDP ist der ehemalige Chef einer Piratenpartei, der Bernd Schlömer, hat sich da mit reingesetzt und wird das formen. Und die ersten Ergebnisse dieses großzügigen Eckstandpapier sieht schon so aus, als ob sie zumindest jetzt erstmal auf der Suche nach Überschneidung sind, dass irgendwie dieses Wenn-Diagramm ihrer eigenen Forderungen und dem, was die Wähler sehen wollen, dass das schon sehr groß auf den sich überschneidenden Teil da hochgelegt wurde. Ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass man kann einfach in Bezug auf Digitalisierungspolitik der letzten 16 Jahre muss man sich echt anstrengen, um dort hinter groß zurückzufallen. Das heißt, die Hürde liegt nicht sonderlich hoch und deswegen ist so alles, was wir jetzt gerade sehen, erstmal schon, dass dir die Kinnlade runterfällt, das geht auch alles, das ist nicht so von innen zerrottet. Vielleicht liegt es daran, dass eine von den Parteien die ganzen letzten Jahre an der Macht gewesen ist und es auch die Partei gewesen ist, der wir persönlich zu verdanken haben, dass zwei der größten Hindernisse im Infrastrukturaufbau in Deutschland uns dort credenzt wurden. Das war ja damals die Schwarzschillingenummer, wo er noch einen Kumpel mit etwas Kupfer im Keller statt Glasfaser lieber noch mal schnell mehr Strippe ausrollt. Das zweite war, wir können super viel Geld verdienen, wenn wir die UMTS-Lizenzen versteigern. Das waren ja so die meines Erachtens größten Fallstricke in der Historie, die auch aus der Partei da immer gekommen sind, die da jetzt gerade abgewählt wurde. Und deswegen bin ich gerade noch echt kindisch-enthusiastisch mit einer Hoffnung, dass das zu sehen, sagen wir, bis gestern gewesen, als dann die große Koalition, also gestern am 27. Oktober, die große Koalition, die jetzt abgewählt wurde, noch mal schnell die Vorratsdatenspeicherungsinitiative dort der EU noch mal um Größenordnung überschritten hat. Also bis gestern war ich da echt gut gelaunt und muss mich da jetzt auch wieder zwingen, dort optimistisch zu bleiben.
Was genau passiert?
Na gestern hat die große Koalition sich noch mal an der EU-Formulierung zu, wie Vorratsdatenspeicherung aussehen sollte, was ja, wie schon öfter festgestellt, nicht mit dem Deutschen Grundgesetz vereinbar ist. Die EU-Position ist schon nicht mit dem Deutschen Grundgesetz vereinbar. Und jetzt ist die große Koalition noch mal mit einer eigenen internen, sagen wir, Thesenpapier dazu aufgefallen, indem sie noch weit über die Forderungen der EU drüber hinweggegangen sind, was sie da alles schon auf Vorrat speichern wollen, inklusive Videochats, was die EU gar nicht gefordert hat und viele andere.
Und das haben die jetzt sozusagen als könnte man mal machen, noch als Vermächtnis dagelassen, oder wie?
Nochmal irgendwie auch als schon mal der EU zugesagt, dass es so wie gerade die Position Deutschlands sei, ja.
Aber zurück zu den Sondierungsverhandlungen und was da sozusagen für Leute drin sind. Ich bin jetzt nicht so ganz sicher, ob ich das richtig verstanden habe, weil das klang einerseits sozusagen als, da könnte was Gutes bei rauskommen. Es klang anders auch so ein bisschen wie, was ich hatte so ein bisschen erinnert an Gleichverteilung, gleichberechtigte Sorgearbeit im Haushalt. Der Mann macht einmal den Abwasch. Und weil vorher noch nie ein Mann den Abwasch gemacht hat, kriegt er sofort auch eine Medaille. Also was ihr da beobachtet, ist es eher das Letztere oder eher tatsächlich berechtigter Grund zur Hoffnung, dass da diesmal was Besseres bei rauskommt? Anna vielleicht?
Ich finde es super schwer vorher schon so optimistisch zu sein, weil das entspricht einfach nicht meiner Natur, glaube ich. Ich wäre es manchmal gerne. Ich würde auch sagen, klar, die Latte hängt tief. Man kann es nicht besonders viel schlechter machen. Und das ist auch gut so. Also nicht gut so für die Vergangenheit, sondern gut so für die Zukunft. Was mich ein bisschen skeptisch macht, gerade wenn man sich so dieses Sondierungspapier durchliest, das ist alles sehr, also vieles darin ist so sehr wirtschaftsbezogen. Wenn man zum Beispiel jetzt irgendwie so sieht, steht dann auch drin, ja, wir wollen einen besseren Zugang zu Daten. Und dann fragt man sich, okay, wofür? Und dann steht da klar, für Start-ups, für kleine und mittelständige Unternehmen und natürlich für die innovativen Geschäftsmodelle in der Digitalisierung. Und da denke ich mir so ein bisschen klar, ich glaube, es wird mehr passieren und vielleicht auch Besseres passieren als so die letzten Jahre, aber mit wem im Blick? Und da sehe ich noch nicht so ganz. Ich meine, klar, das ist erst mal ein Sondierungspapier und da kann noch viel passieren. Und auch die Personen, die da sitzen und das verhandeln, stimmen mich auch eher optimistisch, aber so ganz irgendwie den Braten trauen will ich halt noch nicht.
Na ja, es sind ja erst mal Sondierungspapiere. Wir wissen noch nicht, was im Kurs ist. Es kann, da sind ein paar Sachen, auf die sich geeinigt haben. Sie betonen ja auch nochmal, dass sie nicht gemein zueinander sind, sondern dass es irgendwie alles smooth läuft. Das ist, manchmal denke ich, wenn man das extra nochmal betonen muss, na ja. Es sind Sondierungspapiere, das heißt, wir wissen noch nicht, was im Koalitionsvertrag stehen wird. Das ist nochmal eine Aushandlungssache. Es ist eine generelle Tendenz und Richtung, aber es ist keine Garantie auf irgendetwas. Ich glaube aber schon, wie Anna auch sagt, wir haben jetzt 16 Jahre, ja vielleicht drücke ich das zu, ich war auch ziemlich jung noch vor 16 Jahren, vielleicht kann ich das gar nicht, also irgendwie mein politisches Leben so ab Wahlen beginnt und endet jetzt, also das ist jetzt quasi immer CDU gewesen oder GroKo. Und insofern, ich glaube, man kann sagen, dass es einen Stillstand gab. Deswegen müssen jetzt zwangsweise ein Stück weit Reformen kommen. Es werden Veränderungen eintreten. Ob das jetzt alles so perfekt wird, das kann ich schon mal abstreiten, also das wird es nicht, aber es sind schon mal ein paar gute Leitplanken, glaube ich, in diesen, ich kling selber wie so ein Sondierungspapier, aber ich bin selber vorsichtig natürlich, aber vorsichtig würde ich sagen, es werden ein paar Veränderungen kommen, die uns auch gefallen werden, also die wir gut finden werden. Aber wie gesagt, es ist ein Sondierungspapier, wir müssen mal gucken und es muss jetzt auch einfach was passieren, weil es sind 16 Jahre, es ist einfach etwas komplett verschlafen worden und es war einfach überhaupt kein Fokus da drauf. Was mich schon ein bisschen stutzig macht und da würde mich auch interessieren, was die anderen Gäste so dazu sagen, ist, dass sie sagen, dass sie vieles davon im ersten Jahr erreichen wollen. Also gerade so zum Thema Digitalisierung steht ja wirklich drin, sie wollen das im ersten Jahr machen, was uns auch so ein bisschen, glaube ich, zurückbringt zu der Krux, na ja, mit welcher Expertise denn? Also ich glaube, in der neuen Regierung ist mehr Expertise da. Das sieht man in den, wie gesagt, in den Wahlprogrammen auch so ein bisschen. Da wurde sich ein Kopf gemacht. Da stehen ein paar gute Dinge drin, ein paar Sachen, die ich schlecht finde, aber oder sinnlos, für sinnlos halte. Aber genau, hier steht was davon. Im ersten Jahr der Regierung sollen alle notwendigen Entscheidungen getroffen und durchgesetzt werden, um private wie staatliche Investitionen schnell, effizient und zielsicher umsetzen zu können. Also Modernisierung der Verwaltungsplanung und Genehmigungsverfahren. Genau, wollen Deutschland modernisieren und wie das davon so im ersten Jahr passieren. Also die versprechen ja auch sehr flott zu agieren. Weiß nicht, ob ich das gut finde. Mal gucken, wie das aussieht.
Das klingt so ein bisschen nach Start-up-Mentalität, so wie du es jetzt gerade erzählt hast.
Grundsätzlich ist so eine neue Regierung will halt die Fußtapsen so schnell wie möglich im Zement hinterlassen, bevor der trocknet und das verfliegt. Ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass da irgendwie auch Leute jetzt das erste Mal wieder Regierungsverantwortung schnuppern und dort Dinge umsetzen wollen, die sie selber die letzten Jahre frustriert hat. Das kann man natürlich, wenn man da mit dem Feuereiferderei sagt, jetzt gleich im ersten Jahr so viel wie möglich auf den Weg zu bringen, dann ist das menschlich auch ein Stück weit verständlich. Ich teile aber auch Fionas Einschätzung, dass wenn man so viel Aktivismus an den Tag legt, ohne das mit Kompetenz zu untermauern, wird das im Normalfall schief gehen, nach hinten losgehen. Und von Menschen, die auf der anderen Seite, die jetzt nicht unbedingt zu den Guten gehören, wird das schnell ausgenutzt werden, weil die einfach schon viel länger in diesem Spiel mit dabei sind. Und sich dann vielleicht doch wieder daran bereichern und das teilweise nach hinten losgehen lassen. Also ich kann es nachvollziehen, dass die schnell loslegen wollen, aber vielleicht ist es manchmal auch einmal Muratorium, grob erst mal überdenken und dann die Grundlagen zu legen, die noch nicht schnell sichtbare Effekte bringen, sondern zu sagen, wir müssen erst mal wieder das Grundsätzliche, wir müssen erst mal wieder anfangen, den Boden glatt zu walzen, bevor wir da Autobahnen drauf bauen können. Vielleicht braucht es das dann am Anfang.
Das ganze Auto-Metaphern.
Es fällt langsam auf. Autobahnen in Berlin bauen ist ja auch eher schwierig. Anna, willst du noch zu dieser Geschwindigkeit, die da in den Tag gelegt wird, was sagen?
Ich habe da gar keine Meinung zu, muss ich sagen. Es ist doch was Positives zum Sondierungspapier eingefallen. Ich habe nachgedacht. Was auffällt ist, dass es im Vergleich zu glaube ich allem, was wir von vorher kennen, von den Jahren, nicht so ein absurdes, wir brauchen hier Sicherheit und hier Verschärfung und hier dieses, da steht irgendwie dieser eine Satz drin, es kommt auf mehr präventive Sicherheit an, da denkt man so, was meinen sie damit? Aber ansonsten geht es eigentlich. Also das finde ich tatsächlich auch momentan stimmt mich noch heiter.
Ich würde fast sozusagen schon offiziell gerade einbiegen wollen, aber noch ein konkretes Thema herausgreifen wollen, das ist Bildung. Das ist ja, da gab es ja viel Stress in letzter Zeit und es gab ja diese, ich habe schon wieder vergessen, wie das konkrete Ding ist, es gab ja diese Bildungsmilliarden, die dann irgendwie versickert sind mit der Digitalkampagne, die Digitalinitiative, und dann war es mit Corona ganz schlimm, was digitale Bildung angeht, also sowohl digitale Kompetenz auszubilden, als auch digitale Infrastruktur am Start zu haben, ist das was, was für euch auch eine Rolle spielt, also Bildung nicht im Sinne von die Ministerien müssen Kompetenz werden, sondern im Großteil der Bevölkerung, oder in der ganzen, in der Zivilgesellschaft, da ist das Wort, in der Zivilgesellschaft muss digitale Bildung verankert werden und das fängt halt ganz, ganz vorne an. Oder ist das oder folgt das dann sowieso logisch aus den anderen Punkten, die wir heute besprochen haben?
Ich glaube andersherum. Die anderen Punkte folgen logisch daraus, dass die Bildung sowohl im digitalen zwingende Fortbild, ich sehe es ja immer wieder hautnah in den aktuellen Entscheidungen, Gerichtsentscheidungen zu den Filesharing-Sachen, wo ganz eindeutig die Richter überfordert sind von den technischen Zusammenhängen und sich dort etwas an die Backe labern lassen. Da ist es sehr wichtig, zwingende Fortbildung bei bestimmten Menschen mit Entscheidungskompetenzen zu haben und mit selber Lehrkompetenzen. Also sowohl Lehrer als auch die Verwaltung als auch Richter sollten zwingend Fortbildung im digitalen nehmen, um dort einfach im Beruf fit zu bleiben. Auf der anderen Seite auch, wenn du auf den Querschnitt der Gesellschaft in Deutschland guckst, sind ja die meisten Menschen von ihrem letzten Bildungserlebnis echt lange entfernt. Das heißt, das siehst du ja an der Ausstattung und am Zustand von Universitäten und Schulen. Es ist ja so, dass die meisten Menschen in Deutschland schon ewig keine Schule mehr von innen gesehen haben. Weder als Eltern noch als Schüler selber, weil so wo ist der Durchschnitt der Bevölkerung wie bei 45 oder so. Das heißt, wenn du das mischst mit einem und mit dem Internet kennen wir uns eh alle nicht aus, dann hast du den perfekten Sturm, um sowohl die Bildungseinrichtungen verkommen zu lassen, als auch die überhaupt gar nicht aus dem Radar zu haben, dass die auch digitale Infrastruktur brauchen. Und da braucht es einmal ein ganz großes Bewusstwertungsprogramm, dass wenn du nicht dort an den Stellen, wo wir den grundsätzlichen Unterbau für zukünftige Generationen, die sich da im Digitalen wie selbstverständlich auch souverän und nicht nur auf die großen Unternehmen hörend aufstellen müssen, wenn du das nicht schon in einer grundsätzlichen Politik verankerst und dort auch diesen Ausbau im digitalen Bildungsanrichtung vorantreibst, dann wirst du da in 20 Jahren wahrscheinlich vor den Scherben unserer Bildungsgesellschaft stehen.
Okay, Anna, hast du irgendwie Bedürfnisse oder was ist am wichtigsten, wenn wir über digitale Bildung in Deutschland reden für die nächste Regierung?
Ich glaube, digitale Bildung hast du halt immer das Ding, niemand würde dir sagen, dass das schlecht ist. Also alle sagen, digitale Bildung, supi, brauchen wir. Und die Frage ist halt, wie man die Zugänglichkeit erreicht. Das heißt, man hat ja jetzt gesagt, okay, es gibt einen Digitalpakt für Zeug, es gibt einen Digitalpakt 2.0 für noch ein bisschen mehr als Zeug, aber wie kommt man denn irgendwie da ran? Das ist ja so ein bisschen breitbandmäßig. Man muss ja irgendwie auch das Geld zugänglich machen und nicht nur irgendwo hinwerfen und sagen, komm, holt es euch, indem ihr irgendwie einen komplizierten Antrag ausfüllt. Ich glaube, mehr habe ich gar nicht.
Ja, ich wollte mich da anschließen. Also ich sehe das auch ein bisschen skeptisch. Ich glaube, wer auch immer mit Lehrerinnen und Lehrern näher zu tun hat in den letzten Jahren, weiß, dass so viele gut gemeinten Ansätze daran schallt haben, dass sie einfach höfungslos überfordert sind und wie man arbeitet, weil es gibt wenig Ressourcen. Der Job wird nach und nach weniger attraktiv gestaltet. Das ist ein Knochenjob. Und dann darüber hinaus auch noch irgendwelche Weiterbildungen und Fortbildungen sich drauf packen, um diesen gesteigerten Ansprüchen, also digitale Bildung, auch als Lehrerin oder Lehrer nachkommen zu können. Ich glaube, das ist eine große Herausforderung und das muss man glaube ich immer mitdenken. Genauso wie Digitalisierung von Behörden und so weiter. Wenn du mit Leuten zu tun hast, die überarbeitet sind, dann musst du halt ganz genau überlegen, wie sowas nachhaltig gemacht wird. Ansonsten, ich kenne mich mit Bildungspolitiken nicht so super gut aus. Ich sehe halt nur, dass in den letzten Monaten, glaube ich für uns alle, ein bisschen klar geworden ist, dass es ein Stück weit scheißegal ist, wie es Kindern geht. Und das finde ich ziemlich fürchterlich so zu sehen. Ich hoffe, dass das bessert und keine Ahnung, das finde ich ziemlich unhaltbar, dass nach wie vor keine, dass Ewigkeiten, keine Filter eingebaut wurden, dass Schulen irgendwie so super vernachlässigt wurden. Ich hoffe, dass das ändert. Was ich spannend fand, in dem, das hat ein bisschen mehr mit meiner Expertise zu tun, in dem Sortierungspapier war das Lebenschancen-BaföG. Das schreckliche System muss dringend reformiert werden. Ich finde aber, dass dieses Thema lebenslanges Lernen darin aufgegriffen wird. Ich glaube, das ist eine spannende Sache, wo ich auf jeden Fall ein Auge darauf haben werde, wie sich das entwickelt. Weil ich glaube, dass, nämlich auf jeden Fall mit so Diversität in der Technologiebranche beschäftigt und glaube, dass so ein BaföG oder Förderung für Leute, die aus allen klassischen Förderungsinstrumenten rausfallen, weil sie zu alt sind, weil sie nicht mehr studieren oder weil das ein Zweitstudium wäre, sowas finde ich grundsätzlich erstmal interessant, weil ich glaube, dass es viele Leute gibt, die eigentlich Lust hätten, so eine Art, in Anführungszeichen, Bruch in ihrer Karriere zu haben. Und das finde ich auf jeden Fall ziemlich spannend, weil wenn wir über digitale Bildung sprechen, denken, stellen wir uns oft auch Kids vor und Grundschulen, Oberschulen. Aber ich glaube, dass es darüber hinaus auch noch vier digitale Bildung geben sollte in allen Facetten. Und das kann entweder eine institutionelle Förderung sein von, okay, häng deinen bisherigen Job an den Nagel, mach zwei Jahre eine Ausbildung und ein Studium für drei, vier, fünf Jahre. Und dann haben wir halt eine neue Fachkraft. Das finde ich grundsätzlich erstmal interessant, weil das auch, soweit ich weiß, auch meiner Erfahrung nach vielen Frauen auch noch mal den Eintritt ermöglichen würde. Aber genau, ich glaube, so dieses Thema lebenslanges Lernen und digitale Bildung muss auch jenseits der Schulen stattfinden in einen Altersgruppen.
Es gibt in der Formulierungsschritte der CCC noch ganz viele Themen, die wir jetzt auch nicht besprochen haben. Da geht es irgendwie noch um autonome Systeme, auch um das Lieblingsthema Breitbandausbau, auch das kam noch in unserer Sprache. Also guckt euch das noch mal genauer an, weil es hier auch um den Überbau ging, um das, was man damit erreichen will. Und damit würde ich auch gerne enden wollen und euch fragen wollen, wenn es jetzt, also nicht eine Utopie, also nicht sozusagen wünscht ihr was, sondern wenn ihr das, was ihr jetzt von dem, was gerade passiert, seht, wenn ihr das den optimistischsten, aber noch realistisch bleibendsten Blick in die Zukunft richtet. Ja, also es geht alles gut, aber es ist halt auch im Rahmen dessen, was in Deutschland so machbar ist. In welcher digitalen Gesellschaft leben wir in vier Jahren? Was für guten Dinge können dabei rauskommen?
Ich bin gerade ein bisschen hin und her. Entschuldigung, Marcus, können wir, bevor wir diese, das ist eine interessante Frage, kann ich zunächst eine andere beantworten. Ich bin ziemlich in ein Patch, wir hatten, da stand eine Frage drin, die ich mir sehr zu Herzen genommen habe und nämlich, was fehlt in dieser Formulierungshilfe? Das fände ich tatsächlich nochmal spannend, die Anwesenden zu fragen. Ich glaube, bei Erdgeist ist es ein bisschen schwierig, du hast da mitgeschrieben. Aber vielleicht auch nochmal, Anna, mir selbst habe ich auch nochmal die Frage gestellt, wenn ich darf, darf ich darauf kurz eingehen? Gut, ein Absatz zum Thema digitale Gewalt. Riesengroßes Thema, das hat auch viel mit Plattformregulierung natürlich zu tun. Wir sprechen viel darüber, dass wir Daten schützen müssen und das hat unmittelbar natürlich auch mit Menschen, das hat oder hat mittelbar mit Menschen auch zu tun. Aber wie schützen wir eigentlich Menschen, die online unterwegs sind? Und dazu gibt es zu wenig Forschung. Das hat ganz klare Auswirkungen auf den nicht-online-Space oder auf den Meet-Space, wie auch immer, auf den analogen Space, überträgt sich in Gewalt. Und es gibt eine enorme Radikalisierung und das Thema muss einfach angegangen werden. Steht sogar in einigen Wahlprogrammen drin. Den Sondierungspapieren hab ich jetzt nicht mehr gefunden, aber das ist ein Absatz, der fehlt mir da drin. Wenn wir überlegen, was muss das Internet, was muss Netzpolitik leisten in den nächsten vier Jahren, dann ist das ein Thema, das steht für mich ganz, ganz weit oben. Es taucht in den Statistiken nicht auf. Es ist aber einfach eine Realität für einen großen Teil der Nutzen, der Internetnutzenden und es muss besser erforscht werden. Es muss da mehr Regulierung ran. Es kann nicht sein, dass wir unglaublich viel Stalkerware noch frei verfügbar haben in den App-Stores und so weiter und so fort. Und da müssen Lösungsansätze her und da müssen wir uns, glaube ich, auch einmischen und mit daran arbeiten.
Das wollte ich auch sagen. Ich habe auch noch eine kleine Liste von den Sachen, die mir fehlen. Ah, sehr gut. Ich unterstütze das einfach. Nee, aber damit auch verbunden. Ich habe mich gefragt, ob es Absicht ist, dass es irgendwie nicht so vorkommt. Das ist eigentlich die ganze Plattformfrage und es ist halt auch super schwer, darauf eine Antwort zu kriegen und ich kenne die Diskussion zu dieser Formulierungshilfe nicht, aber wenn es sie gegeben hätte, hätte ich sie mir hart vorgestellt. Aber das fehlt halt und ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen...
Kannst du kurz genau sagen, was du mit Plattformfrage meinst?
Dieses Ganze, was Fiona auch schon meinte, irgendwie, wie steht es um, was ist die Haltung zu Plattformregulierung? Klar, das ist irgendwie nicht nur eine deutsche Sache, aber das ist ja auch was, was irgendwie Deutschland auf einer EU-Ebene beeinflussen kann oder sollte. Und wie gehen wir mit Plattform um? Wie gehen wir mit quasi diesem ganzen algorithmischen Kram auf Plattform um? Muss man damit anders umgehen als mit anderen Sachen, die eben nicht auf Plattformen, sondern in Verwaltungen stattfinden? Und das fand ich spannend. Und ich habe mich gefragt, ob es mit Absicht oder bewusst fehlt.
Die Innenansicht war tatsächlich, dass die Hoffnung ist, dass es aus einer gewissen Souveränität, die sich da erzeugt, ableiten würde, dass wenn wir es schafften, unsere eigenen Open-Source-Plattformen zu bauen, dass wir die Abhängigkeit zu den großen, kommerziellen Werbe getriebenen Plattformen deutlich reduzieren können und mit was Besserem am Start sind, was nicht als Ziel den Benutzer als Ware, sondern eher den Benutzer als Souverän darin betrachtet. Zur digitalen Gewalt, ja, stimm ich zu, hatten wir tatsächlich in der Kürze der Zeit einen blinden Fleck. Es ist schwierig, dort was Konstruktives zu formulieren. Aber ich denke, dass der konstruktive Ansatz wäre dort überhaupt Grundlagenforschung zu dem Thema, zu den Mechanismen, die zu digitaler Gewalt am Ende führen, aber auch zu allen anderen Netzwerkeffekten, die wir haben, inklusive dem Verbreiten von falschen Nachrichten, um zu digitaler Gewalt aufzustacheln, das gerne groß und breit überhaupt erst mal wissenschaftlich zu behandeln und dort einen Fokus drauf zu legen, dass man dort dann tatsächlich fundiert auch überhaupt mitreden kann und nicht einfach nur wettern und sagen, wir hätten gerne, dass der Benevolent Diktator Facebook oder Google dort jetzt dahergeht und sofort alles sperrt, was uns da nicht gefällt, sodass wir den Symptomen so schnell wie möglich hinterherdoktern und dabei den großen Plattformen noch mehr Werkzeuge in die Hand geben. Aber dort sinnvoll diskutieren zu können, braucht es glaube ich viel Forschung. Aber eine Forschung, in der wir auch sagen, dass wir den Ergebnissen am Ende auch ernsthaft zuhören und nicht einfach nur wieder Forschung, die wir am Ende dann wegheften und ein bisschen betreten nicken.
Ich glaube, an dieser Stelle auf jeden Fall auch noch mal lobenswerte Erwähnung von Anne Roth, die auch glaube ich auf Twitter als erstes darauf hingewiesen hatte, dass dieser Absatz fehlt und die glaube ich auch eine Person ist, die sich unglaublich viel damit beschäftigt und auch das Innenleben, glaube ich, davon kennt, was zu dem digitale Gewalt angeht und wahrscheinlich auch ein Forscherkette für einen konstruktiven Absatz. Und was Plattformregulierung betrifft, es ist ein unglaublich komplexes Thema. Aber ich glaube, deswegen ist es umso wichtiger, dass Leute mit facher Expertise, insbesondere technischer Expertise, da auch mit reingehen. Ich beschäftige mich jetzt im Rahmen eines aktuellen Jobs auch viel mit dem Thema und ich weiß aber, dass es da viele, viele Ansätze gibt oder Konzeptionen und Verständnis, so Konzeptionen davon, die in meinen Augen in die falsche Richtung gehen und auch von technischem, angenehmem Sachverstand zeugen. Und ich glaube, da fände ich es total gut, wenn der CCC oder andere Etät mit der nötigsten Expertise da auch mit reingehen in die Diskussion. Ihr müsst, glaube ich, nicht direkt die Antworten haben, aber zumindest damit einsteigen.
Na, wir geben gerne die Plattform auch wieder. Die Anne Roth hatte ja auch auf den Kongress genau zu dem Thema gesprochen. Und solange es dort erstmal die Sichtbeköfte, die Plattform gibt, wird es hoffentlich in dem Kontext auch die Kompetenz dann akkumuliert.
Aber ja, das muss also noch nachgearbeitet werden. Aber können wir jetzt noch den Blick in die Zukunft wagen?
Na, nachdem Fiona das so grandios noch dahinten verschoben hat, darf sie auch als erstes ihre Visionen ausrollen.
Ja, aber Fiona hat die Frage schon wieder vergessen.
Ja gut, so ist das halt mit der Struktur, nicht wahr? Es geht darum, die Regierung steht zum Anfang, in vier Jahren gibt es die nächste Wahl. Was ist das optimistisch, aber dabei noch realistisch seinste, positivste Szenario, was aus dem, was da gerade passiert, erwachsen kann? In welcher digitalen Gesellschaft leben wir dann? Vielleicht auch sogar ganz konkret wir als Personen?
Zwei Dinge, es ist jetzt nicht so übergreifend meta-beantwortet oder nur zum Teil. Zum einen gibt es formalisierte Prozesse und Formate, in denen die digitale Zivilgesellschaft, das digitale Ehrenamt einen Platz am Tisch bekommt und effektiv mitreden kann, nicht nur informiert wird, sondern echte Beteiligung erfährt, echte Transparenz, echte Mitbestimmung und deren Stimme einfach auch zählt und miteinbezogen wird in der Planung, in der Umsetzung von Vorhaben und sei es also auf allen Ebenen, in den Gesetzesverfahren, in der Vergabe von Aufträgen, in der Durchsicht von Anträgen und Verträgen, da sollte diese Expertise oder Community-Anbindung stattfinden oder es muss eine Struktur geschaffen werden, damit das effektiv möglich ist. Und zum anderen wünsche ich mir definitiv ein Aufbau von Förderstrukturen, die flexible, unkomplizierte, nachhaltige Förderung von Open Source ermöglicht. Und das muss in meinen Augen eine, ich glaube, dass eine Bundesstiftung dafür das beste Mittel der Wahl wäre, aber ich kenne mich mit Vergaberechtigungen auch nicht so gut aus, dass ich das mit Sicherheit sagen kann. Aber es braucht ein Förderinstrument, egal bei welchem Ministerium am Ende angesiedelt. Ich glaube, da gibt es verschiedene, die dafür in Frage kämen. Aber es muss vom Staat auch ein Schritt getan werden, um diese öffentliche Daseinsvorsorge zu gewährleisten. Und das bedeutet für mich nachhaltige Förderung von Open Source Infrastruktur.
Ich glaube, so eine sehr positive Vision, wo ich mich wirklich sehr freuen würde, ist, wenn wir in vier Jahren eine konsequente IT-Sicherheitspolitik hätten. Das heißt, wenn in vier Jahren alle verstanden haben, dass es eine echte Sicherheit ist, die sich quasi verteidigt und nicht auf Angriff geht, dass wir keine Diskussionen mehr über irgendwelche Hackbacks führen müssen, dass wir keine Diskussionen mehr über Staatstrojaner führen müssen, dass endlich mal diese unsicklichen Hackerparagrafen abgeschafft sind. Ich glaube, das ist machbar und ich würde mich sehr freuen, wenn das passiert.
Tatsächlich.
Der alte Mann erhebt sich aus seinem Rollstuhl. Tatsächlich. Aus seinem Schaukelstuhl.
Wo klemmt das tatsächlich? Ich habe jetzt hier auch ausgedruckt, noch mal die Formulierungshilfe. Das sind irgendwie so 13 Seiten, in denen wir... Ja, ich wollte auch rascheln.
Warum druckt ihr denn alle Dinge aus? So geht das nicht mit der Zukunft. Wir reden über die Zukunft.
Wir sind das Problem.
Ich glaube, ich kann nicht die ganze Zeit hin und her klicken auf meinem Rechner. Ich würde gerne auch abstreichen, was ich schon hatte. Und tatsächlich ist ja viel von dem, was wir dort zusammengefasst haben, als aktuelle Kritikpunkte. Ich würde mir wünschen, dass es einfach selbstverständlich ist, dass bei der Pflege von Infrastruktur, bei der Pflege von dem, was wir als Almende dieser ganzen Gesellschaft begreifen, dass dort Partikularinteressen viel deutlicher angezählt werden. Sei es irgendwie in so Dingen wie dem Glasfaserausbau überall hin. Alles, was tatsächlich die Zukunftsfähigkeit einer Gesellschaft betrifft, muss es verpflichtende Konsultationen mit so ziemlich allen Beteiligten geben, die dort in einer Generation groß genug sind, darunter zu leiden, wenn wir das jetzt vermurksen. Das heißt, es braucht tatsächlich für mich, für alles, was die Generationengerechtigkeit kaputt macht, im digitalen, aber auch in vielen anderen gesellschaftlichen Bereichen, braucht es für mich eine Plattform, in der Leute angehört werden, die Lust haben, Kompetenz mit beizutragen, die eben nicht nur finanziell getrieben ist, sondern aus einem tatsächlichen Wunsch, die Gesellschaft zu was Besserem zu machen. Und ich glaube, das hat sich an Zynismus eingeschlichen, sowohl Politikern gegenüber als auch von Politikern gegenüber Menschen, die ankommen und was verändern wollen. Und ich hätte mir einfach gewünscht, wenn dieser Zynismus aufhört und man tatsächlich in vier Jahren sagen kann, Experten, die mit ihrer Expertise...
Und Experten, oder?
Ja, Experten, die ankommen und dort beitragen wollen, dass die einfach mit offenen Armen entfangen werden. Und dabei ist dann eben Digitalisierung nur eins von vielen Aspekten, sondern dass Deutschland so im Großen und Ganzen auf seine Spezialexperten und Expertinnen in dem jeweiligen Thema hört.
Ihr gottverdammten Hippies, vielen Dank. Also in einer sicheren Open-Source-Beteiligungsgesellschaft würde ich auch gerne leben. Fiona, Anna, Erdgeist, vielen Dank, dass ihr heute im Chaosradio wart.
Vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Eine Freude.
Viel Spaß gemacht.
Das freut mich sehr. Ihr, liebe Hörerinnen, könnt das gerne noch mal durchlesen. Die Links dazu sind in der Show nur zur Sendung. Ich habe noch einen kleinen Nachtrag aus der letzten Sendung, wo wir über EID gesprochen haben. CK, der da war, hat noch einen ganz ausführlichen Artikel geschrieben über die Hintergründe von Blockchain, SSI und EID. Also wenn ihr diese Sendung gehört habt und dann noch mal genauer einsteigen wollt, gibt es da noch mal mehr Lesematerial. Ansonsten war es das für heute. Ich bin überrascht, dass ich nicht alles anzünden will, was meistens nach dem Ende einer Chaosradio Sendung der Fall ist, sondern ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es einen optimistischen Ausblick auf die Zukunft gibt. Mehr weiter würde ich mich, glaube ich, nicht herausragen. Mir bleibt deshalb nur noch eins zu sagen. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.